G
ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER BUT WILL
SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT BILL MELUGIN, BILL
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN ARIZONA ATTORNEY
GENERAL HE'S ALSO A SENATE
CANDIDATE AND JUST RETURNED FROM
VISITING THE BORDER YESTERDAY.
GENERAL, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
WHAT DID YOU SEE?
>> WELL, I'VE BEEN DOWN TO THE
BORDER NUMEROUS TIMES.
WE ARE LOSING ADJECTIVES TO
DESCRIBE THE ANARCHY AND CHAOS
GOING ON PAIRS DOWN THERE
TALKING TO OUR DEAR FRIENDS,
THEY'VE BEEN DOWN THERE FOR FIVE
GENERATIONS.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THEY'VE NEVER
SEEN IT THIS BAD.
AS A RESULT OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FAILING TO BUILD
THE BORDER WALL, THEY HAVE MS 13
GANG MEMBERS FOR THEM HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE CROSSING THEIR
PROPERTY EVERY DAY.
AS A RESULT OF THAT WE KNOW AND
BORDER PATROL APPREHENDS FOLKS
ILLEGALLY CROSSING THEY GET OUT
IN THE FIELD IN THAT ALLOWS THE
DRUG CARTELS AND THE TERRACE
THEN TO BASICALLY GO RIGHT
THROUGH IT AND BRING THOUSANDS
OF POUNDS EVERY MONTH OF DRUGS
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
ALLOW TERRACE TO SLIP TO THE
SAFETY NET.
JON: WE JUST NOTED IN THE REPORT
FROM BILL MELUGIN THE
PRESIDENT'S NEVER BEEN TO THE
BORDER BUT WHAT WERE YOU TELL
HIM IF HE WERE TO COME DOWN?
>> OF THE STABBED STATE OF
AFFAIRS AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN TWO MORE HUNTER BIDEN ART
EXHIBITS THAT HE HAS TO OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
BECAUSE AMERICANS ARE DYING
RIGHT NOW AS A RESULT OF FAILED
POLICY OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
LITERALLY LAST YEAR I INVITED
HIM, I INVITED VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS WHO USED TO BE A STATE
AG.
I INVITED SECRETARY MARCUS TO
COME BE WITH US, TO COME TALK
WITH US BY THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN
HE COULD SEE FIRSTHAND THE
DAMAGE HIS POLICIES HAVE
BROUGHT.
NOT ONLY TO ARIZONA, BUT TO THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IT'S.
JON: I WANT TO PUT UP THE
NUMBERS THEY ARE STAGGERING
REALLY BETWEEN OCTOBER AND
MAY 2021 -- 202,267,000 FOLKS
WERE APPREHENDED AT THE BORDER
FROM EL SALVADOR.
155,000 FROM GUATEMALA.
ONE OR 37000 FROM HONDURAS.
560,000 FROM MEXICO.
BUT THEN THERE IS A CATEGORY
CALLED OTHER, 616,000 PEOPLE
FROM OTHER NATIONS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT CHINA, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT REALLY
COUNTRIES FROM ALL OVER THE
GLOBE.
WHAT IS THAT SAY TO YOU GENERAL?
>> IT SAYS, PROVES THE POINT
I'VE BEEN MAKING TRY TO MAKE IN
FEDERAL COURT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS
DECRIMINALIZED AND INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE BREAK IN THE WALL.
AND SO THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE
COMING HERE TO BE HOUSEKEEPERS
OR WORK AS BARTENDERS.
AS A RESULT OF THESE POLICIES
YOU HAVE LITERALLY PEOPLE ON THE
CHAIR WATCH THIS COMING.
THE CARTELS FLOODING OUR COUNTRY
WITH THOUSANDS OF POUNDS OF
ILLEGAL DRUGS EVERY SINGLE
MONTH.
SO AMERICANS ARE DYING AS A
RESULT OF THE FAILED POLICIES.
ALSO PAYING THE COST SENT A LIEN
LIVES, WE ARE PAYING THE COST
AND TREASURE AS A RESULT OF THE
SOCIAL SERVICES.
EVERYTHING FROM HEALTHCARE, TO
HOUSING, TO FOOD STAMPS PER THE
BI ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
GIVE TO PEOPLE THAT ARE
ILLEGALLY VIOLATING OUR LAWS.
JON: THERE WERE 19 HIJACKERS ON
911.
WE KNOW THE DAMAGE THEY CAUSED.
NOW WE HAVE GOT 50 PEOPLE
APPREHENDED WERE ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST.
FEDERAL TERRORIST WATCH LIST.
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN AWAY.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
APPREHENDED.
THERE WERE 440,000 KNOWN GOT A
WAYS DURING THE EIGHT MONTHS
FROM OCTOBER OF 21 UNTIL MAY OF
22.
YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER THEY RAN
AWAY THEY OBVIOUSLY ESCAPED LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THAT IS 55 MILLION A MONTH, WHAT
YOU THINK THOSE PEOPLE ARE UP
TO?
>> WELL, JON LOOKED PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE FOR FOLKS.
THOSE NUMBERS YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT THAT'S MORE THAN THE
ENTIRE POPULATION A PLACE LIKE
BUFFALO, NEW YORK.
THESE ARE ASTRONOMICAL AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT 1000 A DAY IN THE
TUCSON SECTOR HERE IN ARIZONA
LOAN, IS SLIPPING INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS WELCOMING FOLKS THAT ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
YOU END UP HAVING A SITUATION
AND YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF IF
SOMEONE COULD BASICALLY WALK
ACROSS THE BORDER, YOU SEE THIS
CURING THEIR CARRY-ON BAGS AND
LUGGAGE AND SURRENDER TO
HOMELAND SECURITY AND BASICALLY
BE LET OUT IN THE COUNTRY, WHAT
ARE THESE PEOPLE DOING GOING
THROUGH 100 PLUS DEGREE
TEMPERATURES, TREKKING THROUGH
19, 20 MILES OF DESERT LIKE
ARIZONA AND SOUTH TEXAS.
WHAT INTENTION DO THEY HAVE?
I WILL TELL YOU YOU DO NOT NEED
TO BE A ROCKET SCIENTIST TO
FIGURE OUT THOSE PEOPLE ARE
COMING HERE TO DO BAD THINGS.
WHETHER THAT'S CRIME IN OUR
INNER CITY, WHETHER IT'S
FLOODING OUR NEIGHBORHOODS WITH
DRUGS, OR GOD FOR BID TERRORI